une priorité a été mise sur la
vaccination des personnes résidant on
n'est pas les autres établissements
d'accueil de personnes âgées qui comme
vous le savez contenu la logistique
complexe des vaccins et rennes qui était
uniquement disponible en début janvier
était une certaine trop s logistique et
sur ce plan je pense qu'il faut se
féliciter des résultats je dirais
féliciter les gens qui ont organisé cela
essentielle ment la task force du
ministère des solidarités la santé
puisque aujourd'hui 85 % des résidents
des bacs sont maxime et au moins ont
reçu un bon pour être précis une dose il
60% à peu près les deux doses donc on a
une couverture qui au delà de ce qui
était espéré avec une très bonne
adhésion de ces personnes âgées à très
âgé et ce qui est évidemment une bonne
nouvelle pour les perspectives de
réduction de la mortalité qui est déjà
observé un ehpad le moindre nombre de
clubs en ehpad
donc c'est un résultat acquis même s'il
n'est pas définitivement équipe à ce
qu'il reste des personnes à vacciner et
chf est entré dans d'autres détails
ensuite sont venues très vite
début janvier la vaccination des
professionnels de santé d'abord les
personnes d'âge des plus de 50 ans avec
commandité dont celle ci se continuer
avec l'arrivée du vaccin serait sénégal
dont j'aurais pas après tout à l'heure
quand vous le savez aujourd'hui tous les
professionnels de santé ça fait 2 3
millions personnes sont éligibles à la
vaccination
à ce jour il y en a à peu près 800
milles qui sont vaccinées ce qui est
insuffisant il ya la problématique
spécifique
j'y reviendrai à propos du vaccin
astrazeneca
ensuite à partir du 18 janvier aussi ont
commencé à maxime les personnages toutes
les personnes âgées de 75 ans environ
cinq millions de personnes en plus des
personnes en ehpad est là aujourd'hui
environ 30% ces personnes ont reçu au
moins une dose et ceci doit avoir un
appât a déjà un impact sur le nombre de
personnes hospitalisées âgées dans les
hôpitaux en france
mais ceci évidemment une bonne chose
même s'il faut poursuivre l'effort il
est largement nourri les îles et il est
largement en cours il ya encore beaucoup
de personnes à vacciner
enfin du fait de la démonstration
d'efficacité du vaccin serait et des cas
chez des personnes âgées grâce à son
utilisation en grande bretagne depuis
peu de vaccination avec astrazeneca est
ouverte aux personnes âgées de 50 à 75
ans avec comment visiter sa présente
presque 5 millions personnes donc c'est
l'axé nations ont commencé depuis ce
mois ci afin déjà un tout petit peu
février donc la suite du programme elle
dépend évidemment complètement des
livraisons de vaccins
donc le rythme à quelle heure le rythme
s'accélère de moire moi même si on
aimerait bien que ça allait encore de 8
mais il ya une limitation du nombre de
doses fournies quelques difficultés de
ci de là d'approvisionnement même si
dans l'ensemble le rythme suivi est d'à
peu près celui qui était attendu
je rappelle qu'à un rythme hebdomadaire
les livraisons de la salle en février
c'était de l'ordre d'un million en mars
est de l'ordre de 2 millions en avril ça
sera de l'or une certitude pour un
vaccin de nouveaux vaccins johnsen entre
3,6 et 4,2 millions de doses par semaine
on met ça sera la carte les 2,5 millions
en juin 1,5 million en juillet 6.5
millions donc on a heureusement devant
nous des perspectives d'augmentation
très significative de monde de l'eau
disponible ce qui devrait permettre par
exemple d'ouvrir la vaccination à toutes
les personnes âgées de 65 ans sans
restriction de 2000 comorbidités ou de
quoi que ce soit dd tout début avril et
j'espère pour les personnes âgées de 50
à 65 ans ensuite qu en avril où est donc
de permettre comme cela a été annoncé
antérieurement donc quelque part permet
d'ici fin du mois de mai que l'essentiel
des personnes vulnérables du fait de
l'âge essentiellement du fait de
comorbidité se soient vus offrir et été
vaccinées sachant tilmans majorité de
ces personnes souhaitent ou le comprend
la vaccination plus donc la nécessité de
vacciner les professionels de santé dans
le même temps et si on veut terminer ce
ce petit panorama prospectifs
donc on peut envisager que le reste de
la population si on veut
arrivés à contrôler la pandémie puisse
commencer à vacciner en juin et tout le
long de l'été avec un nom de doses
suffisant pour que un grand nombre de
ces personnes soient vaccinés
espérons-le beaucoup si vous le
souhaitez on voit revenir sur le sujet
qui paraît très important de l'adhésion
de deux des plus jeunes à la nécessité
de la vaccination qui un sujet à mon
avis assez délicat voilà en gros
aujourd'hui il ya eu 6 millions de doses
injectées en france quatre millions de
personnes ont reçu une dose 2 millions à
peu près à jaro ni les chiffres ont reçu
deux doses
la situation aujourd'hui est celle d'une
diversification des modes de vaccination
est ce qui est une bonne chose il faut
que ça se poursuive
il y a évidemment les centres de
vaccination qui existe depuis janvier en
nombre croissant
et qui va falloir faire pousser en la
fois en nombre de capacités de
vaccination et en nombre pour pouvoir
vacciner plus avec les vaccins arn dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent
donc c'est un premier circuit circuit
qui aujourd'hui est essentiellement
utilisé pour les professionnels de santé
et pour les personnes âgées de plus de
75 ans mais maintenant le circuit
peuvent se diversifier contre compte
tenu d'une certaine équivalence
d'efficacité du les autres avec les
vaccins à adénovirus depuis quelques dix
jours les médecins généralistes peuvent
vacciner avec le vaccin astrazeneca
c'est là que le rythme n'est pas tout à
fait suffisant et il y a un peu de
travail à faire pour que le système se
met en place mais enfin il est quand
même récents et pour lapins pour les
médecins généralistes c'est quand même
une contrainte supplémentaire
on peut comprendre que ça se met pas en
place absolument de dans l'immédiat et
mais enfin souligner sous réserve que
les choses avancent comme on peut
l'espérer on devrait voir se développer
cette vaccination dans les jours et
semaines qui viennent il y ait de 400000
vaccination fait et d'odiah long et 40
mille médecins généralistes se sont
inscrits pour vacciner c'est pas
suffisant estime s'avère une partie la
population n'a pas médecin de jadis qui
vaccinent ce qui est un souci mais là
aussi on peut peut-être penser que les
médecins généralistes s'inscrivent en
plus
et qu'il ya donc davantage dans les
jours ou les semaines qui viennent et
puis à partir de lundi prochain comme
vous le savez il sera possible de
vacciner en pharmacie ce qui est une
très bonne chose et qui viendra
compléter le dispositif de vaccination
par les médecins généralistes et là
aussi bien chez le médecin généraliste
que chez le pharmacien
ce sont donc les personnes actuellement
les personnes âgées de 50 à 75 ans en
gros mais ça pourrait éventuellement des
personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans qui
seront vaccinés qui sont vaccinées des
personnes avaient comorbidités appel que
ça représente un petit peu moins de 5
millions de personnes
donc voilà le paysage mais les
difficultés évidemment les limites
c'est le nombre de doses disponibles je
n'y reviens pas des efforts sont faits
pour maximiser optimiser les commandes
et on voit que heureusement comme cela a
été prévu progressivement le nombre de
doses augmentent et va encore augmenter
très signifiante significativement dans
dans les tout prochains mois il y a eu
les adaptations des indications grâce
aux avancées des connaissances sur les
vaccins et là je voudrais le faire un
petit commentaire spécifique sur le
vaccin astrazeneca parce qu'il est
l'objet et encore maintenant
malheureusement l'objet d'une polémique
injuste non scientifiquement fondées il
faut savoir pour ce vaccin les études
cliniques menées par le laboratoire
astrazeneca ont été faites que chez des
sujets âgés de moins de 65 ans donc la
haute autorité de santé de façon sage
lorsqu'elle a examiné par dont le
dossier de ce vaccin à considérer faute
de données qu'on ne peut pas la ministre
ait des gens âgés de plus de 65 ans qui
évidemment et puis me manque
content de lui la nécessité impérieuse
de vacciner des gens j'ai plus de 60
heureusement dans les quinze derniers
jours trois points 15 jours trois
semaines sont devenues des données
d'abord des causes puis l'angleterre
montrant que ce vaccin est en fait aussi
efficace que de l'axone kaiser pour
obtenir une protection par exemple à
l'égard des hospitalisations donc des
formes graves de la maladie et ceux ci
ça c'est très important
y compris chez les personnes âgées parce
que là bas ils ont vacciné les personnes
âgées et ou de laque soit au delà de 80
ans donc fondés sur ces informations
capitales avec
analyse de centaines de milliers de
personnes vaccinées les recommandations
ont légitimement changé et maintenant il
est donc possible de vacciner à tout âge
avec le vaccin sera gênée car c'est
parfaitement justifié de personnes
d'efficacité il reste à continuer de
convaincre d'abord les professionnels de
santé eux-mêmes les médecins
généralistes à vacciner avec cette astra
zeneca et la population concernée que il
n'ya pas perte de chance on est en
vacciner parle astrazeneca comparé à une
vaccination par le vaccin files heures
il faut répéter ce message qui est juste
là la vérité scientifique je viens je
passe beaucoup de temps à le faire
d'autres le font aussi
il sait très important que tout le monde
en soit convaincu pour la bonne marche
de la campagne vaccinale
il ya eu un autre souci avec ce vaccin
c'est le fait que celle et un souci
relative chez les personnes jeunes
relativement jeune 20 30 40 ans il peut
donner dans les 48 heures qui suivent la
vaccination une espèce de saumon
grippale désagréable la filiale a des
frissons céphalées les gens sont pas
bien et évidemment les gens on renâcle
un peu à l'idée de la bête malade 48
heures alors d'abord c'est pas tout le
monde c'est transitoire c'est pas grave
c'est désagréable et surtout ça peu
sucrés venir en grande partie avec le
paracétamol donc là il ya un effort de
conviction à faire notamment à l'égard
des jeunes professionnels de santé qui
n'avance pas assez vite dans la dans
l'acceptation de cette vaccination
j'espère que le message va être entendu
j'ai l'impression d'après les données
des derniers jours que la progression la
vaccination des professionnels de santé
s'améliore et que donc cet obstacle et
je l'espère derrière nous mais c'est pas
tout à fait sûr comme vous savez
ailleurs en l'air la discussion
éventuelle d'une obligation de
vaccination chez les professionnels de
santé si on n'obtenait pas des chiffres
satisfaisants compte tenu évidemment du
caractère absolument fondamental de la
vaccination des professionnels de santé
pour le bon fonctionnement du système de
santé pour éviter les infections
nosocomiales
bref pour des raisons éthiques et
pratiques de santé publique
absolument évidente donc voilà pour moi
les notions essentielles que je
souhaitais vous indique
j'imagine que les pleins de questions et
j'y répondrai bien volontiers merci
merci beaucoup pensé point il est en
effet important de clarifier le
changement de l'extension de l'astra
zeneca et et si en effet je comprends
votre première réponse concernant la
différence entre l'europe et et la
grande bretagne
on peut quand même remercier la grande
bretagne d'avoir permis nous donner
ainsi des des données des données
scientifiques sur la place en ayant une
politique plus offensive
alors on va faire des séries de
questions donc bernard jomier on va
prendre 5 5 commissaires et ensuite il y
aura une deuxième série vous pourrez
répondre à l'issue des cinq questions
bernard jomier qui ont à distance alors
je vais poser la question puisque
bernard jomier et à une obligation à
illéla n'ont donc il va poser la
question et et on lui transmettra la
réponse qu'il doit partir total alors
vous remercie beaucoup
là près d'andorre proposé de me poser la
question je suis je m'excuse d'avancé
auprès d'alain fischer parce que je vais
j'ai un rendez vous à 11h30 et je
voudrais peut-être pas le temps
d'écouter la réponse les ados remercie
beaucoup pour sa présence merci à
catherine de roche d'avoir organisé
cette audition ces deux questions à
poser à un petit chiot la première c'est
que il semble que les données qui
remontent des hôpitaux c'est qu'il ya de
plus en plus de personnes de moins de 60
ans qui souffrent de formes sévères de
la coved qui sont hospitalisés qui sont
même en réanimation en gros que la
baisse de l'âge moyen en réanimation
n'est pas qu'un effet de protection des
plus de 85 ans mais il ya bien une
hausse
voilà en chiffres bruts des personnes
jeunes en réanimation
or la stratégie vaccinale actuellement
visait à protéger d'abord les 14 15
millions de personnes vulnérables dont
les moins de 60 ans en gros ne faisait
pas partie donc est-ce que ça modifie
notre stratégie vaccinale et surtout
notre capacité à protéger rapidement le
système hospitalier
la saturation est ma deuxième question
porte sur les personnes souffrant de
pathologie mentale sévère
la haute autorité de santé dans un avis
du dm de mars à recommander leur
vaccination donc même les personnes
jeunes le 4 mars olivier ferrand ne
s'est pas exprimé sur cette question
est-ce que cet avis de la has va être
appliquée et dans quel délai voilà merci
beaucoup merci madame la présidente
non mais c'est devant d'un afficheur de
répondre rapidement donne un show me et
qui présidait ailleurs mission sur la
suite du coffee donc faire une exception
vous avez complètement raison sur le
logo mentation du nombre de personnes
relativement jeunes aujourd'hui en
réanimation dont il ya deux facteurs qui
interviennent
il ya quand même la réduction il ya
quelques chiffres qui le montrent de ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle du nombre de
personnes âgées grâce à la vaccination
mais il ya aussi les faits divers et des
variants spécifiquement en france
essentiellement du marié envie
britannique qui est largement
prédominant sont fort moselle voilà la
réunion et à mayotte
mais à lire partout ailleurs en france
elle variant britannique et domine ce
variant et il est pas plus sévère mis
les plus contagieuses donc ni l'ailier
toute la problématique actuelle de la
persistance de la pandémie en france à
niveau un niveau relativement élevé
alors qu'on voit le harrier le virus
initial s'estomper et celui-là pré
nominés avec un coefficient de de
contagiosité plus élevée qui explique
qu' un peu plus de personnes plus jeunes
qu'ils soient effectivement en soins
intensifs
est-ce que ça doit amener à modifier la
stratégie vaccinale en termes
qualitatifs je dirais non parce que mme
néanmoins les personnes plus âgées
restent beaucoup plus fragile que ce
soit en mer ou de nombre
d'hospitalisations au nombre de décès ça
change pas le le risque pour une
personne donnée d'être malade gravement
malade de décéder évidemment le message
c'est d'aller au plus vite s'est
accélérée tant qu'on le peut la
vaccination
bon déjà le fait qu'on
vacciner des gens à partir de 50 ans
avec facteur de risque on sait que c'est
cela qui sont réunis mation le nombre de
personnes rebelles en réanimation par
exemple est très important donc une
partie de ceux là devraient pouvoir être
être protégés dans les toutes prochaines
semaines puisque leur vaccination est en
cours
et puis comme je le disais tout à
l'heure j'espère bien que dès début
avril on vaccinera toutes les personnes
âgées plus de 65 ans et puis assez vite
ou avril
toutes les personnes âgées de plus de 50
ans on devrait voir à ce moment là un
impact plus fort au niveau des rennais
réanimation concernant le vote seconde
question sur les pathologies mentales
sévère la recommandation de notre
conseil est la même que celle de la
chasse c'est à dire de prendre en compte
absolument ces pathologies pour que ces
personnes soient vaccinés effectivement
j'ai pas vu passer un avis directe du
ministère mais defacto je sais au moins
d'un certain nombre d'endroits
c'est fait et je pense que nous pouvons
tous insisté auprès du ministère que ça
soit absolument officiel il n'y a pas de
discussion sur l'indication de
vaccination des gens qui ont des
pathologies mentales sévère alors ceux
qui sont à l'institution ça avance pas
mal mais diamant heureusement d'ailleurs
tous ces patients ne sont pas en
institution et doit bénéficier au plus
vite de la vaccination quel que soit
leur âge merci beaucoup et maintenant
nous allons passer à la suite des
questions alors florence lassarade merci
beaucoup madame la présidente merci
professeur fisher bon beaucoup de
questions tu étais déjà abordé moi je
voudrais avoir votre sentiment sur la
façon dont les médecins sont utilisés
traités dans cette stratégie vaccinale
d'abord avec un petit flacon par semaine
avec des gens à convoquer maximum deux
jours pour utiliser le flacon ensuite la
semaine suivante mais cette semaine on
leur dit alors qu'ils ont commencé à
bien organiser leur leur système de
vaccination parce qu'on me demande quand
même une surveillance après le vaccin
on leur dit non mais cette semaine n'ont
pas te pas de pas de vaccination pas de
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que sur
le terrain les gens qui ont plus de 50
ans ou 65 ans qui cherche à se faire
vacciner
ils prennent plusieurs portes d'entrée
ceux qui sont très débrouillard ils vont
être sur trois quatre sites en même
temps y compris chez leur médecin
traitant et ils obtiendront avec ce qui
arrive pas à se débrouiller avec
internet ils restent sur la touche donc
il ya une inégalité total une
incompréhension des médecins qui peut
être la semaine suivante pour dire après
tout concédé bruissant nous puisque on
nous traite de cette façon là et
dernière chose que je voudrais aborder
c'est la vaccination des jeunes moi
j'étais avec 40 étudiants la semaine
dernière en visio qui réclament à cor et
à cri la reprise une vie normale on sait
que c'est par les jeunes que l'épidémie
galope
est ce qu'on pensait qu'il faut pas
envisager assez rapidement de vacciner
les étudiants et je dirais les la
population plus jeune comme c'est fait
dans certains pays européens même post
break site
même si corinne imbert on va prendre 500
questions corinne imbert ben oui merci à
la prison de merci professeur de
batterie du temps avec le membre de la
commission des affaires sociales ce
matin j'ai venir sur le début de votre
intervention concernant et puisque
signifier présent sur démarrage poussif
par rapport à la grande-bretagne
parce que ce qui nous a un peu étonné
ici au sénat c'est que lors d'une
audition du groupe d'amitié france
allemagne l'ambassadeur d'allemagne en
france a dit effectivement bien sûr il a
confirmé cette commande au niveau
européen
des doses vaccinales mais il a rajouté
que chaque pays avait la possibilité de
commander des hausses vaccinale
supplémentaire à ce que vous pouvez être
vous êtes au courant de ça est ce que la
france qui aurait peut-être par choix
délibéré ou miser sur le
futurs vaccins sanofi pasteur se serait
privé aurait renoncer à certaines
commandes de vaccins ou pas voilà c'est
juste une besoin d'un éclairage de votre
part je vous remercie très bien m'a
repérée chez merci madame la présidente
merci monsieur professeurs je voudrais
juste en préambule est très court
quand même saluer tous les élus les
maires et leurs conseils municipaux
ainsi que les professionnels de santé
actifs et retraités qui permettent quand
même la diffusion sur le territoire de
la vaccination qui ont été proactif qui
l'ont proposé d'ailleurs très tôt je
reviens sur l'astra zeneca parce qu'il
se trouve qu'aujourd'hui des personnes
de 80 ans et plus appelle encore la
plateforme 08 cent et quelques
puisqu'ils n'ont pas accès au vaccin
puisque cela fait défaut et on commence
à l'heure alors proposé l'astra zeneca
alors moi j'avoue que je suis un peu
perdu dans toutes les explications
en préambule vous avez rappelé qu' il ne
s'adressait ça il s'adresse aux
personnes âgées jusqu'à 75 ans ensuite
il me semble que vous avez parlé d'une
d'une étude qui permettrait d'aller au
delà et j'aurais aimé connaître la
notion de personnes âgées s'il vous
plaît merci
il a donc chantal de scène chantal de
seine et ensuite laurent burgoa mc le
professeur fisher répondre merci madame
la présidente professeur je voulais vous
interrogez sous la sous vaccination des
professionnels de santé
il semblerait que les médecins soient
largement vacciner mais au fur et à
mesure que l'on descend dans la chaîne
de soins
il semblerait qu'il y ait beaucoup
beaucoup de réticences et on dit que
globalement il y aurait 30 % des
professionnels de santé vaccinés et en
conséquence je voulais savoir quel était
votre point de vue sur l'obligation
vaccinale des professionnels de santé et
bien laurent burgoa et ensuite le
professeur fisher répondre à cette
première salve de questions
oui merci mme allard la présence merci
professeur moi j'aimerais revenir
professeurs sur l'intérêt de travail
ascione aa matière de santé puisque on
voit depuis quelques semaines que le
gouvernement souhaite territorialisée sa
politique sanitaire bâtir de en matière
de couy donc on voit que de nos jours il
ya une vingtaine de départements où le
taux d'incidence sont très forts est-ce
que sur ces vingt départements
il pourrait y avoir une politique de
vaccination différente si par exemple le
préfet et les élus de ce département
souhaité pour éviter des mesures plus
coercitives je pense notamment à un
confinement que nous souhaitons pas
justement ce que peut avoir une strie de
un changement de stratégie pour endiguer
la pandémie très bien sous les répondre
professeurs à se première question et
ensuite nous aurons deux deux autres
séries m
face heures ok c'est bon vous n'entendez
d'accord donc la question concernant la
façon dont les médecins sont traités
dans la campagne vaccinale donc le
rappelle que les médecins peuvent depuis
une huitaine de jours peuvent vacciner
qu'ils ont pour quarante mille d'entre
eux médecin généraliste avait à peu près
deux tiers commander les vaccins
pas tous pour l'instant ce qui est un
problème en soi parce que ça veut dire
qu'un tiers des de nos concitoyens qui
ont un médecin traitant non pas un
médecin traitant qui vaccinent
aujourd'hui donc c'est une difficulté et
qui j'espère se résoudra par
l'application progressive de deux des
médecins de beaucoup d'entre eux de ce
qui n'est pour l'instant ne se sont pas
inscrits pour la vaccination est aussi à
travers la vaccination en pharmacie nos
premiers points
le second point concerne le faible
qu'initialement le nombre de flacons
disponibles étaient limitées
effectivement parce qu'il n'est pas très
grand nombre de vaccins à disposition
mais néanmoins et c'est une des
difficultés qui a conduit à cette
incompréhension et c'est clairement ses
maladresses de communication
ce début de semaine c'est qu'il ya
aujourd'hui enfin il ya les je ne sais
pas aujourd'hui mais il y avait lundi
quatre cent mille quatre cent mille
doses de vaccin astrazeneca qui était
quelque part entre les pharmacies et les
médecins qui n'avait pas été utilisé
alors qu'en principe ils auraient dû
l'être il avait été commandé pour que
les vaccins soient soient menées et là
il ya une difficulté qui est totale j'ai
discuté avec un certain nombre de
médecins généralistes ces derniers jours
d'un côté les médecins généralistes ont
joué le jeu à fond qui se sont engagés
qui ont pris les rendez vous et qui ont
commandé leur vaccin et que administrer
leur verse 1 et qui se retrouve
maintenant transitoirement pour quelques
jours mais en difficulté de ne plus
avoir de doses disponibles pour vacciner
et de l'autre médecin je leur jette pas
la pierre mais c'est un fait qui se sont
engagés mais qui n'ont pas vraiment
vaccinez vous donc il ya un déséquilibre
complexe qui fait qu'à une accumulation
de doses non utilisées alors qu'ils
auraient dû être utilisées et de l'autre
côté des frustrations de médecins qui
n'arrivent pas à vacciner je pense que
cette affaire sur le plan de la
communication a été très mal traités
mais il faut quand même la remettre dans
ce contexte général
il faut ensuite relativiser les choses
c'est que le les médecins ont fêté la
fin de cette semaine
devons pouvoir recommander à nouveau des
vaccins et donc il y aura pas vraiment
d'interruption et que les doses les
doses commandées pourront être
administrés
je pense que ceci et doit être clair
mais il faut aussi que qu'il y ait un
engagement un peu plus fort des médecins
dans cette campagne
même s'il de façon très heureuse la
complémentation de la vaccination par
les pharmaciens et je l'espère et je
crois c'est le cas très souvent sur le
terrain par une bonne entente locale
entre les médecins et les pharmaciens et
une possibilités de flexibilité qui va
aller 300 par le fait que les deux
peuples et deux types de professionnels
de santé vont pouvoir et à signer ils
vont pouvoir s'entendre pour savoir qui
vaccinent quoi qui vaccinent qui pardon
dans sur un territoire donné
donc je pense que progressivement les
difficultés de mise en place des
difficultés communication et cetera de
devrait s'estomper
juste un point parce que vous avez parlé
de la nécessité d'une surveillance des
personnes avec le vaccin astrazeneca ya
pas vraiment nécessité de surveillance
évidemment dans les deux trois minutes
qui suivent
mais la préconisation de surveiller
pendant un quart d'heure les personnes
après vaccination ça concerne les
vaccins arn en raison des risques de
chocs anaphylactiques choc
anaphylactique dont le risque avec les
vaccins strazeele et le type astrazeneca
est infiniment plus faire donc il n'y a
pas nécessité pour un médecin ou un
pharmacien ou quiconque de garder un
quart d'heure à proximité la personne
qui vient des plaques si c'est juste
pour préciser et après ce coup c'est un
élément de simplification de la
vaccination
globalement les médecins généralistes
avec les doses déjà commandés et ses
petits vont être commentée maintenant
elles vont disposer leurs millions 600
mille doses pour passer pour maxime et
leurs patients donc seule chose qu'on
peut souhaiter c'est que effectivement
ces deux souhaitent utiliser et qu'un
maximum de sujets on en parlait tout à
l'heure de l'importance de vacciner
rapidement puisse l'être très très vite
la seconde question de madame concerne
les jeunes et leurs aspirations
légitimes à un retour à une vie normale
est ce qu'on peut envisager de vacciner
les étudiants plus vite que ce n'est
prévue aujourd'hui la difficulté par
définition section maxime les étudiants
avec signera - les personnes âgées les
personnes malades
et objectivement même si on a tous envie
que les étudiants puissent retourner
mener une vie normale le plus vite
possible
décemment il paraît difficile de priver
du vaccin quelqu'un qui a un risque
d'être hospitalisés qui est 50 fois
supérieure ou 20 fois supérieure en
fonction de son âge et qui risque avec
un risque de mort de cet ordre de
grandeur plus élevé je pense que c'est
pas possible et l'immense majorité des
pays
pour pas dire la totalité ont fait le
même choix que la france c'est à dire
depuis villégier les personnes en
fonction des facteurs de risque de
gravité de la maladie
le seul message il est majeur évidemment
c'est que dès que possible
pouvoir vacciner les étudiants
logiquement les jeunes étudiants et pas
que pas que les étudiants d'ailleurs
devrait pouvoir commencer à vacciner
vers le mois de juin pour l'été donc il
ya encore malheureusement à tenir deux
trois mois mais décemment je ne vois pas
comment on peut remettre en cause une
politique qui pré équipe qui protège en
priorité les personnes fragiles très
fragile que comme cela a été fait la
question suivante
de quoi monsieur inverse concernait le
concernant la possibilité éventuelle de
chaque pays d'acheter des vaccins en
plus de ceux qui sont délivrés à travers
les achats communs des communautés
européennes écouter à ma connaissance je
suis pas plonger dans les négociations
européennes
bien évidemment c'est pas mon rôle mais
à ma connaissance n'est pas la cas sauf
des situations un peu sauvage peut faire
que je qualifie de sauvage c'est ce que
fait par ou la hongrie qui obtient
inquiétant dans la communauté européenne
s'est fait vibrer du axa russe et
vaccine et la pologne je crois aussi de
façon relativement intense avec le
vaccin russe bien enrichie vaccine pas
la bouille de vaccins russe mais c'est
une autre question de la nature
politique dont la france comme l'immense
majorité des pays et l'allemagne
elle-même jouent le jeu d'une
vaccination avec le vaccin qui ont reçu
l'autorisation de la communauté de
l'agencé européenne du médicament
je pense que ce qui n'est pas le cas
comme vous le savez pour l'instant de
max à russe ou chinois éventuellement ce
qui est quand même une garantie de
sécurité et de sérieux sur les produits
que nous administrons nous faisons
administrait à nos concitoyens
l'allemagne a comme même situation en
place
si vous regardez où en est la même dans
vaccination c'est quasiment la même
chose que la france a porté le nombre
d'habitants n'y a pas deux sur commande
et de jeu individualiste
en dehors de quelques pays de l'est ce
n'est pas le cas la question du
l'administration du vaccin astrazeneca
alors je confirme que la limite n'est
pas 75 ans il n'y a pas de limite d'âge
à l'utilisation des vaccins et des cas
donc c'est tout à fait légitime qu'une
personne âgée de 80 ans ou plus qui
n'arrive pas encore malheureusement ça
peut encore arriver à avoir un
rendez-vous dans un centre et qu'on
puisse lui offrir un vaccin sénégal il
faut le faire c'est très bien je répète
que les résultats en particulier en
écosse et à oublier le plus grand nombre
de personnes et analyser mais aussi
d'angleterre
à ce propos montrent que ces vaccins
sont aussi efficace que le vaccin de
pfizer
donc c'est une tout à fait une bonne
proposition qui a été faite à la
personne le plus beau des métiers et il
faut que cette personne accepte cette
proposition d'être vaccinés par le
vaccin astrazeneca
ensuite se pose la question des
provinciales de santé qui est
effectivement une question sérieuse
le rythme de croissance de la
vaccination il a un petit peu plus élevé
que les chiffres que vous donnez à
veiller au 7 février 34 % des
professionnels de santé ors et pas été
vaccinés
46% des professions de santé en ehpad
c'est insuffisant mais un petit peu
moins mal que ce que vous disiez je
l'indiquais c'est aux derniers jours il
semblait avoir un frémissement positif
avec plutôt un rattrapage
peut-être que les différentes campagnes
et il est surtout localement les
interventions de beaucoup de médecins de
beaucoup de professionnels de santé en
général des différents ordres
médecins pharmaciens infirmiers etc qui
ont qui engage qui encourage qui incite
fortement leurs collègues à se vacciner
commence à porter ses fruits
il n'est pas exclu que le par ailleurs
que le fait le plus con cept
d'obligations à 6 n'a été évoquée aussi
porte un tout petit peu assez fluide
moment comment ma vision des choses
on y travaille avec notre conseil on va
élaborer un avis là dessus mais notre
vision c'est en gros de dire qu'il y a
encore la place même s'il faut aller
vite pour de la pédagogie pour la
concertation pour de l'explication avec
tous les professionnels de santé en
s'aidant de tout le monde et en
particulier de leurs propres collègues
je pense aux infirmiers par exemple
l'ordre des infirmiers la plupart des
syndicats font un très bon travail pour
essayer de persuader leurs différents
membres de leur corporation à se faire
vacciner maintenant si ce travail
savard est insuffisant disons dans
quinze jours va je n'allume baril après
6 je pense que la notion de l'obligation
vaccinale se discute
comme vous savez les spé les profils de
santé sont origine de se vacciner contre
le virus de l'hépatite b s'est pas faite
pour une protection personnelle dans ce
cas là mais en tous les cas cela montre
que c'est un gars au moins un précédent
et donc c'est un sujet qui pourrait être
évoquée compte tenu la nécessité que
cette version se protéger eux mêmes se
protègent entre elle évite au maximum
les infections nosocomiales est aussi se
montre exemplaire à l'égard de de la
population puisque évidemment on va
vouloir leur parlais à l'instant dans
les mois qui viennent vacciner un
maximum il faudra vraiment un maximum
pour enrayer la pandémie compte tenu de
la contagiosité des variants donc un
maximum de personnes dont il faut être
exemplaire donc si on n'arrive pas par
la pédagogie mais on peut comprendre
qu'il faille un petit peu de temps ce
souci légitime
bon il faut rassurer sur l'efficacité
sur la la tolérance de ces vaccins mais
l'obligation vaccinale je dirais c'est
le dernier recours
comme vous le savez c'est du domaine
législatif donc vous aurez dans ce cas
là vous auriez en débattre donc voila
mon sentiment est la dernière question
portait sur éventuellement la modulation
la vaccination en fonction de de
l'incidence est de vacciner plus dans
les régions à forte incidence dans cela
est déjà été fait soit dirait de façon
quantitative ou qualitative je
m'explique quantitative dunkerque ont
hâte maritime il ya des doses
supplémentaires de la kz1 qui ont été
livrés et en moselle c'est qualitatif la
moselle est particulière
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure parce que
dans ce département il se trouve que le
variant dit sud africain qui est un peu
plus embêtant en termes de risque
d'échappement à l'immunité naturelle est
prédominant et comme on a une
incertitude encore on n'a pas les
informations sur l'efficacité du vaccin
astrazeneca à l'égard de ce virus
c'est de façon spécifique et le massif
either inutilisés en moselle est
d'ailleurs géré a géré par et que le
taux de vaccination en moselle c'est
franchement accéléré ces derniers temps
et c'est une bonne chose donc on peut le
concevoir effectivement que de continuer
à moduler la la délivrance des vaccins
en fonction de deux des poussées de tel
ou tel territoire de la pandémie en même
temps il faut être conscient que quand
par définition laversin n'agit pas
immédiatement pour les vaccins à rnc en
gros il faut 12 à 14 jours pour les bac
cela on dénote adénovirus c'est plutôt
18 21 jours dont il ya malheureusement
un délai pendant lesquelles il n'y a pas
de la vaccination n'apporte pas de
bennes supplémentaires mais c'est pas
une raison de ne pas le faire et au cas
par cas en fonction de ces
problématiques soit de varian soit de
pousser d'incidence n'est pas illégitime
de moduler la vaccination et le nombre
de doses à porter pour que celle ci se
produisent au moins dans les populations
ciblées et je dirais ans à nouveau et
chez les profs seaal de santé pour des
raisons évidentes de bon fonctionnement
du système
voilà merci qu'aucun nous avons encore
pas mal de questions donc monsieur
théophile
je vous entends pas mon merci pour
toutes ces informations utiles moi je
voudrais attirer l'attention sur la
situation en outre-mer qui est
préoccupante et hétérogène temps par la
hausse des cas en guadeloupe les
confinements mayotte et en nouvelle
calédonie qu par les réalités logistique
et les caractéristiques démographiques
différente de ces zones enfin les
chiffres de la vaccination des personnes
prioritaires sur ces territoires sont
bien plus faibles qu'en mai en hexagone
pour pas quelle mesure la vaccination
pourrait être accélérer efficacement sur
ces territoires où la confiance n'est
parfois une barrière supplémentaire est
vraiment exponentielle par rapport aux
autres territoires
merci brigitte micouleau merci madame la
présidente monsieur le professeur
je voudrais d'abord me faire l'écho des
médecins formés content je les ai eus ce
n'est une bonne dizaine de toulouse la
semaine sainte en début de semaine qui
après a passé des heures sur les
dossiers médicaux se sont vu refuser des
vaccins après avoir passé là aussi des
heures à leurs données rendez-vous sont
obligés de remettre les rendez-vous jeu
l'efficacité de la vaccination est avant
tout permet l'immunité une mg unités
de groupe et cette immunité de groupe je
voudrais bouchité dans l'obligation de
faire vacciner les enfants je le cite
c'est un mal transitoire pour en bien
sur le long terme
alors vous avez répondu à la question de
catherine de chantal desseigne sur
l'obligation vaccinale
je sais que c'est du domaine législatif
mais je pense qu'avant d'en arriver là
il faudrait peut-être élaborer une
stratégie pédagogique pour les rassurer
et lever les doutes et dissiper les
doutes qu'ils ont c'est à vous de nous
expliquer comment on peux se peut lever
les doutes
madame sur le groupe on y merci merci
madame la présidente merci professeur
pour vos informations
alors si j'ai bien compris la
vaccination protège des formes graves
mais on n'est pas certain qu'elle
protège de contracter la maladie est en
tout cas traçons certaine de la propager
alors c'est pour ça que j'attendais avec
une certaine impatience une campagne de
communication grand public qui avaient
été annoncés afin que les personnes
vaccinées continue à bien maintenir les
gestes barrières afin d'éviter que la
campagne de vaccination de ce double
d'une flambée de la propagation de la
maladie
en fait hier pour la première fois j'ai
vu un spot de cette fameuse campagne
publicitaire alors on y voit une grand
mère qui est tout content de se faire
vacciner et
juste après ses petits enfants se jette
dans ses bras et tout le monde
s'embrasse et il est écrit en tout petit
une fois que vous êtes vacciné il faut
conserver les gestes barrière j'ai
trouvé que le film n'allait pas du tout
avec la légende
et voilà est-ce que vous croyez pas
qu'il est maladroit de laisser entendre
au grand public que la vaccination
permet de sauter dans les bras
je vous remercie et c'est vrai c'est
très juste cette neuro marque que moi
aussi j'ai pensé la même chose daniel
chasse à gagner chez sa mère merci à
narbonne et madame pensait mourir encore
une troisième série
merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le professeur deux questions
première question les professionnels
sont peut vacciner leurs réticences
eh bien le vaccin serait aînés câble ne
serait pas actif sur les variants
notamment africains deuxième question
lorsqu'on fait une vaccination maison de
santé ce qui est vraiment confortable
c'est de pouvoir être en binôme avec une
infirmière pour moi d'abord pour d'abord
il ya un examen du malade préparation
des vaccins prise de la tension
artérielle surveillance certificat de
vaccination est également rendez vous
donc vous nous avez répondu un petit peu
en disant qu avec astrazeneca y avait
pas de surveillance mais jusqu'à présent
on le faisait donc la question que je
voulais vous poser
l'infirmière on a interrogé la sécurité
sociale l'infirmière n'a pas droit au
remboursement
donc dans ma propre main dans ma maison
de santé on reverse des honoraires à
l'infirmière mais c'est dommage que
l'infirmière ne puisse pas être
remboursés et bien bernard bonne et
ensuite madame oui merci monsieur le
président de metz merci au professeur
fisher première question rapide de
comparatifs en pourcentage si vous
l'avez
entre les différents pays notamment en
allemagne italie et israël alors pas en
nombre à mais en pourcentage
ensuite comment expliquer les paroles de
notre cher ministre de la santé qui
prévoyait qu avant la fin juillet début
août
60 millions de personnes seraient
vaccinés alors qu'on en est aujourd'hui
au bout de deux mois et demi à 6
millions et qu'il en reste 50 4 millions
à faire en cinq mois
troisième question est ce qu'on pourrait
clarifier le calendrier réel et
communiquer correctement sur la
vaccination au niveau des personnes
qu'elles soient avec ou sans
comorbidités parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas on nous dit un jour que les
personnes pourront être vaccinées la
telle date
quand elles ont 60 ans encore me dit et
à d'autres mamans dit autre chose
bref il faudrait vraiment clairement un
calendrier qui explique à tout le monde
et puis aussi un mot sur des médecins je
crois qu'il est très ennuyeux quand même
de les montrer du doigt parce qu'on a
reçu de la part de nombreux syndicats de
médecins des plaintes comme quoi il
avait reçu en un mois plusieurs
directives contradictoires ou qui
s'agitait les unes aux autres qu'ils
sont pour la plupart très volontaires
pour vacciner tout le monde qu'il y a
quelques fois des problèmes ridicule au
niveau des départements
on ne peut pas aller d'un département à
l'autre même si on est très proches ce
qui est le cas à beaucoup d'endroits
bref ne mettons pas les médecins en
difficulté aujourd'hui on a vraiment
besoin d'eux et si on veut vacciner les
54 millions de personnes qui restent
essayant en tout cas de les aider dans
sas et bien et pour terminer
raymonde poncet manger ensuite le
professeur fisher répondra merci madame
la présidente monsieur professeurs oui
il faudrait revenir mois ci sur les 35 %
de soignants thaksin et il faut quand
même rappeler parce que c'est vrai que
ça vient de 10 et campagne un petit peu
de stigmatisation des professionnels de
santé sont assez désagréable parce que
je rappelle quand même que pour les
soignants il a été conseiller une sorte
de stop and go quoi c'est à dire d'un
d'arrêter en fin ou du moins de faire
une rotation et un espacement dans les
services de la vaccination de ces
soignants
ça a été l'occasion d'un service de
soins infirmiers à domicile qui a été
complètement désorganisée par
l'absentéisme des effets secondaires et
qui désormais fait ça au goutte-à-goutte
quoi
d'autant plus que vous devez le savoir
les effectifs ce manque de partout et
donc maintenant c'est quelquefois part
limitée que léonce fait vacciner tous
les trois jours
donc il ya à cet effet d'espacement et
de rotation dans des services super
tendu en terme en termes d'effectifs
donc forcément ça va plus lentement je
voudrais aussi revenir pourrait savoir
si vous êtes si on est bien si j'ai bien
compris
effectivement pour les soignants
beaucoup de soignants demandent à avoir
le choix avec le vaccin à arn à ne pas
se alors pas tant pour ses effets
secondaires on a bien compris qu'ils
étaient mineurs sauf pour l'organisation
des services
mais surtout ça vient d'être dit parce
que ce vaccin est peu efficace très peu
efficaces par rapport aux variants
d'afrique du sud et donc j'aimerais
vraiment me voir confirmer que dans en
moselle en réunion et à mayotte c'est un
vaccin arn qui est proposé aux soignants
et qui pourront pas voilà et
que cette politique vaccinale un petit
peu ce me disent se modifie moi j'irai
un peu plus loin alors de façon sûre
qu'elle soit proposée en moselle réunion
mayotte mais aussi que pour les
soignants que soient ouverts quand même
la possibilité de réserver leur vague de
préférer le vaccin arn parce que il a
été difficile de se faire vacciner
une première fois sera difficile de se
faire vacciner
le jour que ce scénario se diffusant
très bien alors voilà deuxième série de
questions je vous laisse répondre
professeurs et l'ensemble nous aurons
encore une deux trois quatre cinq six 6
questions
première question c'est un outre-mer est
un vrai sujet parce qu'effectivement on
regarde les chiffres de vaccination
autres mairies sont significativement
moindre leçon en métropole avec des
données évidemment il ya des notions
contradictoires c'est une population
plus jeune en moyenne au québec il ya
moins de personnes à la première
priorité mais il y en a quand même
beaucoup et si on regarde parmi les
personnes prioritaires il y en a
relativement peu de vacciner donc là il
ya il y a des difficultés est clairement
de logistique
bien que je sais que des efforts sont
faits pour que les vaccins arrivent au
niveau des différents territoires
d'outre-mer il ya la question qui a été
évoquée de la confiance effectivement
remonter le conseil scientifique je sais
pas si vous avez vu son avis mais qui
sur son site a fait un travail assez
remarquable analyse la situation dans
les territoires des différents de nos
différents territoires d'outre-mer il ya
là confie la question de la confiance
dans la vaccination est il présente en
métropole mais elle est infiniment plus
prévenante et là bas et cela et posent
difficulté et donc il ya un gros effort
et pédagogie à faire on y revient mais
encore plus les plus importants dans les
limbes ans dans ces territoires
évidemment ça repose beaucoup sur les
professionnels de santé qui doivent
essayer de convaincre leur patientèle de
du bien fondé de la vaccination
c'est un souci ça ne se résoudra pas du
jour au lendemain donc ces pédagogies
pédagogie pédagogie explication plus
donc livraison accélérer les vaccins et
réunion mayotte
donc c'est le sait
les deux territoires où il ya une
prédominance du dollar et un sud
africain où le vaccin
pfizer et est préconisée est de fait
utilisé mais ces halles je suis d'accord
avec monsieur théophile je crois son nom
sur le fait que l'ailé ces territoires
sont une source de soucis pour des
raisons multifactorielle que j'ai
évoqués je pense que tout le monde doit
leur euphorie les manches pour essayer
progressivement en particulier de
convaincre les populations de bien
vouloir se faire vacciner
ensuite plusieurs d'entre vous sont
revenus sur la problématique des
médecins tous les cadres de mon point de
vue est bien évidemment recherche donc
aucune raison de les stigmatiser au
contraire on n'a aucune envie c'est de
les remercier et de les encourager à
participer à l'effort national de
vaccination
ils ont réclamé pendant longtemps à
juste titre de pouvoir être associé à la
campagne ils le sont depuis très peu de
temps c'est le vaccination grâce à la
note la possibilité d'utiliser le vaccin
astrazeneca
il y a des contraintes qui sont bien au
fait et on sait incontournable que ces
vaccins sont délivrés sous forme de
flacons de dix doses
donc ce n'est pas aussi simple que la
vaccination antigrippale il faut
organiser des séances de vaccination
cela dit qui mieux qui peut mieux que
les médecins qui connaissent leur
patientèle savoir quelles sont leurs
malades prioritaires et cd aussi des
malades eux mêmes qu'ils aient qui les
appelle pour organiser ces séances de
vaccination le clairement il ya eu un
cafouillage mais encore une fois il est
plus de communication que réel sur la
sur la capacité des médecins de taxi
mais il dispose de doses il ya beaucoup
de doses encore a utilisé par les
médecins
j'espère que par ailleurs que les
médecins qui ne sont pas encore engagés
dans la campagne de vaccination s'y
engageront en complément bien sûr des
des pharmaciens voilà il faut je pense
que je rappelle clairement il ya eu des
maladresses de la part du gouvernement
sur la façon de parler et de s'exprimer
ce lundi mais globalement c'est évident
que le vision générale que les quartiers
mais je sais aussi que ces séries
ministère aujourd'hui c'est d'associer
au maximum les les médecins à cette
campagne en sachant qu'il ya quelques
contraintes
en même temps et de façon juste les
médecins sont rémunérés
pour cette pratique c'est pas une
générosité c'est juste mais il est bien
qu'il en soit ainsi et que les médecins
donc s'associe au maximum à cette
campagne sur la question d'immunité
groupe je suis pas sûr d'avoir tout à
fait compris une partie de la question
ce que vous me citez concernés notamment
les enfants
je pense que c'est vous faites référence
plus au travail qui a été fait il ya
quatre cinq ans dans la mise en place de
la l'obligation vaccinale chez les
nourrissons qui et qui évidemment n'est
pas le même sujet même si on reparle un
tout petit peu l'obligation vaccinale
aujourd'hui pour l'instant il n'y a pas
d'actualité la vaccination des enfants
même si c'est pas rigoureusement
impossible que plus tard ce sujet
viennent à l'ordre du jour en fonction
de la circulation du virus chez des
enfants
peut-être vous le savez et les
laboratoires sont en train de faire des
essais cliniques chez les enfants pour
tester l'efficacité et la sécurité des
vaccins
donc si c'est nécessaire on verra bien à
l'automne au plus tard de vacciner les
enfants ça sera éventuellement
envisageable mais c'est à l'actualité du
tout stratégie pédagogique pour lever
les doutes
oui bien sûr et je pense que c'est la
priorité avant d'envisager une
quelconque obligation vaccinale sa
stratégie de pédagogie elle implique les
professionnels de santé qui sont au
contact de la population
elle implique les organisations au
niveau les agences régionales de santé
elle implique beaucoup de monde moi mais
moi j'ai le jeu
chaque jour je vais pratiquement je fais
des exposés à un grand nombre de
professionnels de santé des différentes
régions pour leur expliquer autant que
je le peux enfin leur donner les
informations dont je dispose sur les
caractéristiques des vaccins et la façon
de vacciner c'est un effort collectif
qui est qu'il faut développer bien
souvent après il ya une question
concernant le risque de propagation
autrement dit la transmission la
problématique de la transmission qui
était prélevé du virus est ce que les
vaccins préviennent la transmission
c'est une question essentielle qui est
on espérer si la réponse est positive
d'arriver plus vite à une unité go bien
sûr même s'il faudra vacciner beaucoup
de monde j'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure en
raison du niveau de contagiosité du
marieur britannique qui est présent qui
prédomine très très largement en france
et dans le reste
europe aujourd'hui il ya quelques
notions mais elle ne sent pas
suffisamment solides pour l'affirmer
mais à travers les données de la
vaccination en israël qui laisse espérer
qu effectivement vaccin pourrait
prévenir la transmission cela est montré
sur la réduction des formes dites
asymptomatiques fondée uniquement sur la
détection dit pcr donc de la présence du
virus
on verra ce qu'il en est mais ont une
fois les données ne sont pas consolidées
au point qu'aujourd'hui on puisse
l'affirmer c'est évidemment un sujet qui
est analysé et suivi de façon très
attentive gestes barrières bien
évidemment aujourd'hui avec ont tenu du
nombre de personnes vaccinées dans notre
pays il n'est juste pas possible
d'envisager de réduire le les gestes
varia cela n'a aucun sens
ce la vie dans des circonstances très
précise de contact intrafamiliales de
personnes vaccinées je pense que dans
peu de temps on devrait pouvoir proposer
d une pelouse et le monde le franglais
de greenline de recommandations deux
états unis viennent de sortir de telles
recommandations je pense qu'on peut le
temps elles seront aussi en france qui
permettent pour une famille donné dans
un texte très précis en fonction de la
vaccination des gens d'envisager de se
retrouver alors critiqué le spot sur le
fait qu'il serait maladroit parce qu'ils
laissent espérer qu'une personne âgée
peut retrouver ses petits-enfants
permettez moi de ne pas être d'accord
pour les personnes en ehpad c'est
aujourd'hui une réalité possible donc
une femme une perte parce que dans le
film c'est une femme et un homme bien
sûr qui est vacciné peut quitter les
pannes enfin retrouvé sa famille et dans
des conditions précises retrouver ses
petits enfants dans ce jeu évidemment ce
n'est pas encore possible pour toutes
les personnes âgées mais ça l'est en
partie et c'est une perspective qui
n'est pas irréaliste dans un délai pas
très lointain pour les autres personnes
âgées
donc je pense que ce spot il indique une
partie la réalité d'aujourd'hui
il tend vers une aucune réalité à cours
relativement court terme même si je ne
peux paraître complètement précis et que
je pense qu'il est important de
sensibiliser la population en savez
je majeur je le répète des semaines et
les mois qui viennent à l'importance de
cette vaccination
donc personnellement je défends
fortement ce spot
notre conseil on a poussé à ce qu'ils
soient diffusés assez rapidement des
genres je suis content qu'il est était
donc je me permet d'exprimer avant la
team des cinq heures avec les ballades
la personne qui n'avait sénatrice qui
est qui a évoqué ce point personnel de
santé et variant sud africain et eva et
astrazeneca
alors attention on a on n'a pas du tout
lié la notion ne va que le vert le dax
astrazeneca n'est pas efficace sur le
variant sud africain on a même des
données dans un modèle animal or il faut
être très prudent parce qu'on ne peut
pas extrapoler totalement mais le
meilleur modèle animal de la maladie
c'est chez le hamster icher le hamster
le vaccin astrazeneca protège contre la
mal à la pneumonie provoquée par le
variant sud africain je ne prendrai pas
cette donnée pour dire tout va bien
c'est sûr que c'est bon ça suffit pas
mais c'est plutôt encourageant et le
fait qu'on n'utilise pas ce vaccin en
moselle par exemple c'est uniquement
parce qu'on ne sait pas non pas parce
que il ne marche pas mais parce qu'on ne
sait pas on par mesure de prudence
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
partout ailleurs en france
métropolitaine en dehors de la moselle
le variant un sud africain et soit
inexistants soit un tout petit peu
présent dans les départements autour de
la moselle mais sans augmentation
d'incidence de du colis d'une manière
générale ceux ci est surveillée de très
très près donc il n'y a aucune raison
mais absolument aucune raison de ne pas
être vaccinés ou qu'on soit un
professionnel de santé ou pas avec le
vaccin astrazeneca dont je répète que
son niveau d'efficacité est absolument
identique au vaccin à irène donc il n'ya
pas lieu de modifier la ligne sur ce
point l'heureux les infirmer je pense
que madame vous avez absolument raison
là il ya un sujet ce que malheureusement
pour l'instant mais j'espère qu'ils vont
la haute autorité de santé va réviser
son point qui était que les infirmières
pour l'instant ne bluffons peuvent
travailler dans le maine de vaccination
que sous la responsabilité d'un médecin
le souhaite c'est que les infirmières et
la délégation complète dans la 2
capacités de vaccination ce qui sera
notamment important lorsqu elles vont
vacciner à domicile avec des unités
mobiles ce qui est important pour les
personnes personnes arrivent à mobilité
réduite excusez moi ou ou dans le cadre
d' aller vers vers les populations
précaires la haute autorité de santé a
été sollicité pas plus tard qu'à 48
heures sur ce point et j'espère qu'il va
bouger
je suis complètement d'accord avec
comparaison avec allemagne italie israël
en israël évidemment c'est un cas
particulier c'est une espèce de
laboratoire à l'échelle d'un pays petit
pays mais pour le monde entier sur
l'efficacité de la vaccination
puisqu'ils ont réussi mais massivement
en disposant très vite la très très très
grand nombre de doses ils ont
aujourd'hui en moyenne vacciner chacun a
su noda s'est pas pressée 60% des gens
reçu 60 60 et 70 % ont reçu une dose et
autres 40 et 50 ont reçu deux doses
évidemment ce qui est très intéressant
oui comme information qui vient d'israël
c'est que ça apporte la confirmation
donc empirer elle que le vaccin en
l'occurrence pfizer c'est celui qui
était utilisée là qu'est venu là bas et
efficaces prévient les hospitalisations
prévient les décès prévient les formes
asymptomatiques j'en ai parlé est très
bien toléré globalement donc ce qui est
une une très bonne nouvelle
juste une remarque il lui était
absolument impossible pour l'europe de
faire la même chose ce qu'il arrive
l'europe entière 400 millions
d'habitants donc ça veut dire qu'on
aurait aujourd'hui administrés 400
millions de doses ça veut dire plus que
leur total des doses qui ont été
administrés grandement donc ce qui est
possible pour un petit pays ne l'est pas
malheureusement pour la communauté
européenne ne l'est pas pour la france
l'allemagne et l'italie
donc là les chiffres de l'inclination à
bas l'italie sont quasiment
superposables aux chiffres français donc
en france on en est à 80 chaque fois je
me trouve dans les huit 8 points 5 doses
administrées pour cent personnes
je crois face les chiffres d'hier en
allemagne ça doit être neuf et en italie
peu près la même chose et on est par
contre la france ayant vacciner plus de
personnes âgées clairement que l'italie
par exemple et donc avec un bénéfice à
temps
du en termes de protection à court terme
meilleurs mais on est vraiment dans les
même ordre de grandeur à des à des
chiffres là prêt entre l'allemagne
l'italie et l'espagne
l'annnonce de lieux du ministre le
concernant la capacité de pouvoir
vacciner potentiellement toute la
population cet été elle n'est pas
irréaliste
elle est liée au fait qu' on n'est pas
dans un système de l'inr croissance de
la vaccination enjeux en termes de à la
fois de vaccination effectuée et de
doses on a doublé entre janvier et
février
double et en double entre mars et
février on va presque doubler entre
lille et mars est double et certainement
au niveau de mai donc la croissance et
les pas linéaire elle est exponentielle
et on doit permettre compte tenu du
nombre de doses sauf catastrophe
industrielle mais qui seront disponibles
en juin juillet août
je vous répète c'est l'ordre de grandeur
de 5 millions de doses par semaine
en juin c'est ça va au delà de 6 6,5 en
juillet août
si on fait les calculs pourvu que les
vaccins arrivent réellement il ya quand
même très fortes chances que ce soit le
cas et que les personnes soient et
confiance dans la vaccination pour moi
je le répète
voilà pour la troisième fois c'est un
sujet central c'est l'adhésion en
particulier les plus jeunes mais on
parlait des étudiants tout à l'heure
mais aussi des gens pour 30 ans ou 40
ans qui ne se sentent pas forcément
menacé par le comique et leur adhésion à
la vaccination il y a le potentiel pour
les vacciner tous cet été je le confirme
et donc il faut juste s'y employer pour
que cela se fasse alors le calendrier
réel comme y invite le calendrier réel
c'est que l'objectif c'est qu'en mars on
puisse avoir en faire en sorte que
toutes les personnes âgées plus de 75
ans et eu au moins leurs premières doses
que potentiellement 60 % en dix ans
passant de 70 % des des professionnels
de santé se soit vacciné et que les
objectifs ehpad il est atteint il est
même dépassé donc je n'y reviens pas et
pour les personnes atteintes de
pathologies de comorbidité donc pour la
vaccination vient de commencer 4,5
millions que lors qu'ils aient acquis
puisse recevoir leur première dose
entre mars et la première moitié d'avril
mais je vous rappelle que l'objectif
c'est d'ouvrir la vaccination sans
restriction aux personnes âgées de 65
ans tout début avril et ensuite courant
avril fin avril c'est difficile d'être
plus précis aux personnes âgées plus de
50 ans ont sans restriction et
qu'ensuite donc on arrive à mai juin
ouvrira au reste de la population mais
c'est très difficile d'être quand même
plus précis que ce calendrier la
continuer
compte tenu de fully du rythme des
vaccinations ça implique les centres de
vaccination deviennent plus augmentent
leurs capacités
donc il faut ils font plus de
s'entraider centre avec plus de débit de
vaccination ce qui veut dire il faut des
personnes
donc il ya tout un travail important de
recrutement personnes impliquées
notamment des étudiants qui sont très
volontaires c'est assez remarquable
ces étudiants en médecine les étudiants
infirmiers etc et de les impliquer dans
la vaccination est bien celui là on doit
vouloir y arriver les médecins n'en là
je ne reviens pas les professions de
santé
bien sûr qu'il faut payer aucune raison
il ya vraiment aucune raison de le faire
elle-même ce serait assez scandaleux
et je pense que c'est bien d'espacé un
peu les injections de des vaccins
astrazeneca pour des personnes
travaillant dans la même unité pour
éviter si jamais il ya trop d'effets
secondaires qui est trop personnes qui
s'arrêtent en même temps mais j'ajoute
encore une fois que l'utilisation du
paracétamol permet de réduire grandement
à complètement mais grandement ces
syndromes grippaux et doit éviter
quasiment toutes absentéisme
donc on peut rassurer expliquer rassurer
ces personnes elles peuvent se faire
vacciner sans désagrément majeur un
petit désagrément un peu de fièvre
ok d'accord on a tous connu ça avec la
vaccination est à nous le choix du
vaccin n'est pas justifiée je le répète
sauf moselle et quelques deux
territoires outre-mer
la problématique du sud africaine n'est
pas une problématique et encore une fois
je rappelle que ce vaccin peut pas dire
qu'il ne soit pas efficace on a
simplement un défaut d'information
pas du tout la même chose et que il est
parfaitement efficace sur le vainqueur
britannique qui représente aujourd'hui
50 à 80 % des virus isolés dans tous les
départements français sur la moselle
donc pour une fois aucune raison de ne
pas utiliser ce vaccin astrazeneca et
donc les professionnels de santé peuvent
et doivent se faire vacciner il faut
répéter ce message l'expliqué convaincre
j'espère qu'on y arrivera dans les
prochains jours voilà très bien merci
nous allons continuer les questions
auparavant si vous pouvez en fin
d'audition nous faire un point sur les
vaccins actuellement en cours de deux
mots location
éventuels sur les sur les six à des
traitements on nous avait annoncé à
lille des essais cliniques sur un
traitement de la maladie donc si vous
pouviez aussi nous faire ce qu'on aille
par rapport aux variants britannique
donc d'après ce que je comprends le var
et enfin le virus initial qu'on a connus
lors de la première vague en voie de
disparition est remplacé par variant
britannique est ce qu'il ya au-delà dé
la question de revenir sur la gravité
des signes on nous dit qu'il y aurait
moins de deux signent un peu pataud
gnoumani commettait la gueuse ivan
hausse mais initialement et moins dans
ce variant est ce que vous pouvez
confirmer les différences et puis je
vais passer la parole à notre collègue
dufour ensuite viviane malaise madame
cohen the valley une belle madame
apourceau poly et monsieur savary donc
monsieur dufour
oui merci le président merci monsieur le
professeur pour ses explications
moi si vous voulez je vais revenir
brièvement à des considérations basique
c'est que depuis plusieurs mois on
entend sur les plateaux de télévision
plusieurs professeurs avaient des avis
parfois contraire on ne sait pas trop
quelle est la vérité pour revenir au
sujet qui nous occupe sur la vaccination
il ressort de ces conclusions des
différents intervenants professionnels
médicaux dont je ne fais pas partie que
la vaccination en définitive c'est la
solution à cette pandémie
néanmoins le ministre verra nous
annoncer 80 millions ça sert des
millions pas pardon de l'acccident à
sion pour le pour le film août prochain
franchement je n'y crois pas le premier
ministre aujourd'hui une part de 20 des
32 millions ça serait peut être une
bonne chose mais on est loin du compte
pourquoi ça d'ailleurs été posées par
nos collègues on n'a pas en dehors de
l'union européenne ne s'est pas procuré
des vaccins par ailleurs c'était
possible à mon sens mais ça n'a pas été
fait et aujourd'hui ce qu'est le plus
dingue et année vous l'avait indiqué
dans vos propos c'est que même les
personnes vaccinées
seront contaminées dont personnellement
la question que je vous pose
je suis assez pessimiste et je vois que
l'année 2009 21,6 voulait va continuer
comme nous le vivons aujourd'hui c'est à
dire avec des distanciation des
restrictions liberté d'aller et venir de
restaurants des cinémas etc
et je crains que m à l'avenir eh bien
nous soyons obligés comme dans des pays
d'afrique comme dans des pays d'asie blé
de porter le masque en permanence où la
dispensation social a minima deuxième
question qui a été posée par bab le
président est effectivement ou un étang
de la recherche sur le traitement de
cette pandémie
merci bien viviane malin comme vous
l'avez dit le variant sud africain est
très présent dans le stade
notamment à mayotte et à la réunion et
vous avez déjà répandue à l'efficacité
du vaccin traces des cas sur ce variant
c'était une question que je voulais
poser mais aussi la certitude que les
autres vaccins dont nous disposons
protège du var yann discute africain est
ma deuxième question c'est actuellement
nous avons des problèmes biologiques
pour des problèmes de logistique la
vaccination ne pourra se ferme ni dans
les officines ni dans les cabinets
médicaux
y aura-t-il des centres de vaccination
supplémentaires ouverts dans ces
départements pour être plus proche de la
population et on aurons-nous des doses
supplémentaires
mais à notre disposition merci pour vos
réponses
laurence cohen où ils merci madame la
présidente
alors il ya beaucoup déjà de questions
qui ont été qui ont été posées moi
j'aurais quand même à mon tour aurait
insisté sur le fait qu' il y a quand
même une organisation assez chaotique
par manque de doses et par exemple comme
l'ensemble de mes collègues j'ai quand
même été alertés par les médecins et
notamment par jean paul hamon qui est le
président d'honneur de la fmf et qui a
dit que alors qu'il y avait une
organisation pour que les médecins
libéraux soient vraiment bien dans la
boucle puis se vacciner et bien le fait
qu'il y ait l'élargissement aux
pharmaciens ce qui est tout à fait
positif et demande est attendue a
complètement bouleversé l'organisation
donc il ya il ya quand même des progrès
à faire en logistique dans notre pays
parce que si finalement par manque de
doses en désorganise quelque chose qui
marchait on risque pas de pouvoir
vacciner dans de bonnes conditions et le
maximum de françaises et français donc
c'est quand même ça que je voulais
apporter dans la discussion la deuxième
chose c'est que je pense qu'il n'est pas
souhaitable de culpabiliser et de et de
m comment dirais-je un peu de jeter
l'opprobre sur les personnels soignants
en s'étonnant que ils ne sont pas ils ne
sont pas vaccinés pourquoi et bien parce
qu'il faut quand même savoir que en
pleine pandémie on a contraint un
certain nombre de soignants d'aller de
continuer à exercer en hôpital alors
qu'ils étaient qu'ovide échos vide voilà
tester kovi kovi de plus donc je veux
dire que et aujourd'hui on dit oh là là
ils sont pas vaccinés c'est pas bien
alors quand on sait pertinemment qu'on
manque de doses je crois qu'il faut
faire attention dans la façon dont nous
communiquons peut pas hier les applaudir
et aujourd'hui avoir un
quand même un discours de
culpabilisation moi je pense que ça
passe par la pédagogie par l'explication
et surtout par un nombre de doses
suffisant enfin lalalalalala 3e
troisième chose aussi c'est que moi je
l'obligation vaccinale ne me convainc
pas je pense que c'est toujours par le
je le redis par la patte par la
pédagogie est d'autant moins
convaincante quand on manque on manque
de doses et d'ailleurs c'est pourquoi je
pense qu'il faudrait quand même
réfléchir plutôt que de réfléchir un
passeport vaccinale moi j'aime bien la
notion de passeports sanitaire où on
aurait la possibilité de voir
effectivement si on a eu la possibilité
de se faire vacciner
et benda voir ça sur son ce passeport
mais par contre avoir l'obligation
d'être testé si les j'espère qu'un jour
les restaurants les salles de spectacles
vont ouvrir etc
si on n'est pas vacciné qu'on ait au
moins un test qui permettent de montrer
que l'on n'est pas porteur de l'aco vide
et que donc on peut on va pas contaminer
les autres
et ma dernière remarque que c'est
concernant ya quand même des on sait
qu'il ya des des personnes via les
soignants qui est qui on veut qu'il faut
qui nécessite effectivement une
vaccination mais moi je pense que aussi
une autre catégorie ce sont les
personnels enseignants
or j'ai été quand même assez surprise
d'entendre monsieur blanc caire disent
qu'on allait pas rajouter une obligation
liée au métier et que donc ça voulait
dire que les personnels enseignants
n'étaient pas spécialement prioritaire
donc vous voyez je veux dire qu'à un
moment donné
la communication c'est un cafouillis et
en fait ça n'entraîne pas une confiance
et limpidité qui devrait y avoir pour
qu'il puisse y avoir plus de personnes
vaccinées qu'on vienne à bout de cette
pandémie
je vous remercie c'est jean marie
vanlerenberghe merci présidente merci
monsieur le professeur beaucoup
d'explications je reviens sur les
vaccinations des professionnels de santé
notamment et professionnels
ayrault je pense notamment aux
auxiliaires de vie qui travaillent à
domicile
je pense aux infirmières aussi qui vont
à domicile et j'ai constaté en discutant
avec elle qu'il ya pas mal de
difficultés d'accès pour avoir des
rendez vous la prise de rendez vous et
la prise de rendez vous de tous et de
toutes les personnes ordinaires si j'ose
dire est ce qu'il faudrait pas une fille
à privilégier pour favoriser
effectivement la vaccination de ses
personnels deuxièmement vous avez fort
justement donner des chiffres concernant
les livraisons hebdomadaires et ce qui
serait pas utile et opportun de refaire
un tableau comme nous l'avions en
janvier et émanant du ministère de la
santé sur les vaccins la répartition
suivant les types de vaccins un tableau
assez complet et actualisé
ça me paraît très nécessaire à cette
époque de l'année et dernière question
sur le professeur j'ai constaté
habitants les hôtes français en
particulier le pas de calais une
certaine inégalité non seulement dans la
vaccination mais aussi pour les tests
il y avait beaucoup plus de tests dans
le pas de calais que dans le reste des
hôtes france et de la france est moins
de vaccins
après faut pas trop s'étonner évidemment
d'avoir des critères et des thés et et
des indices et qui était défavorable
alors est ce qu'on peut espérer que à
l'avenir on est une
disons non pas une priorisation parce
que je crois que c'est en cours pour le
pas de calais mais simplement une forme
d'égalité de répartition sur le
territoire sur des critères qu'ils
soient connus tout le monde merci
beaucoup c'est cathy apourceau poly et
on terminera avec ça va oui merci bien
madame la présidente
écoutez la situation continue monsieur
le professeur à se dégrader dans le pas
de calais et j'ai eu tout à l'heure le
maire enfin le président des maires
frédéric leturque et il me disait à
juste titre au confine en vaccine 1 on
est confiné vous le savez c'est une
véritable souffrance pour les gens de
mon département
d'abord d'être en couvre feu toute la
semaine et est d'être confiné le week
end quand même on est un des
départements de france donc qui est
vraiment dans une grande détresse et une
grande souffrance
on a fait une on a eu vendredi soir un
coup de fil soudain de la rs qui a
retrouvé dans le fond d'un tiroir tard
et ils 18000 vaccin alors franchement on
a dû s'organiser
vendredi soir en catastrophe avec les
élus du département
on a ouvert un centre de vaccination
donc qu'ils étaient prêts à la salle
bertinchamps et je remercie à lens je
remercie d'ailleurs les élus trans
partisan ce pas pas de problème là c'est
pas un problème on en est tous voilà
puisque le maire je suis communiste et
je rappelle que le président des maires
dans département est plutôt à droite est
à droite d'ailleurs donc voila et
centriste 1
donc vous voyez ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas une question partis politiques
ah voilà monsieur albert voilà donc ce
n'est pas une question parti politique
c'est une question d'unité des élus
autour de ça est donc juste quand même
pour dire que je je je demande
franchement solennellement et nous
allons faire un au gouvernement de
continuer sa campagne de vaccination
parce que il faut que nous puissions
sortir de ce confinement
parce que c'est pas possible que l'on
reste est à 18 heures le week-end et est
confiné la semaine est confiné le
week-end
donc on demande à ce que la campagne de
vaccination puisse continuer si on a
trouvé dim 18 mille doses dans un tiroir
on peut bien en trouver tous les mets
toute la semaine pour qu'on continue
cette campagne de vaccination 1 et puis
deuxièmement je ne comprends pas ce mode
de fonctionnement
je le dis je suis dans une colère noire
parce que là avoir réussi à mobiliser
des personnels avoir réussi en un temps
record un an une soirée parce que je
rappe
je rappelle quand même que le vaccin
c'était du kaiser qu'il est valable cinq
jours et si nous ne l'utilisons pas dans
les cinq jours
eh bien il n'était plus valable et donc
on ne voulait surtout pas perdre ces
doses de vaccin est ce qu'on n'aurait
pas été plus efficace en donnant au fur
et à mesure aux médecins dans nos villes
ces vaccins plutôt que de les garder
dans un tiroir quel intérêt at on garder
des vaccins dans un tiroir et de nous
les sortir un vendredi soir à 18 heures
voilà est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas intérêt
à programmer les choses à ouvrir nos
centres de vaccination et a donné les
vaccins aux médecins au fur et à mesure
voilà c'est la question je pose parce
que finalement on a commencé la campagne
de vaccination et heureusement que les
élus de ce département et les bénévoles
et les hospitaliers sont efficaces parce
que on a commencé par vatine et les plus
de 75 ans après on a appelé les plus de
70 ans
après on a appelé les plus de 60 65 ans
et après les plus de 50 ans parce que
finalement vous voulez vraiment écouler
ces deux de vaccination voilà donc je
trouve que c'est vraiment une honte
moi je le dis hein une honte de
pratiquer de cette façon là et oui comme
le président des maires dans le
département jeudi au confine au rac sin
merci on remercie on comprend deux fêtes
cri de colère de notre collègue et pour
terminer monsieur le président de l'amex
on n'est pas le favori
oui merci beaucoup rage me choque
professeur monte encore de terrain on
voit bien que la territorialisation dans
les nombres dans la distribution des
nombre de vaccins est intéressante sauf
que c'est au détriment des autres donc
ne l'oublions pas et ça pose un problème
moi je vois bien vous nous dites 8,5
administration de 12 pour cent personnes
moi dans mon département de la marne le
grand est où on a particulièrement
souffert
j'en suis à 5,7 doses par personne
1 date d'hier comme dans les rues de
france et comme dans le grand test
donc soyons attentifs à cette
répartition deuxièmement en ce qui
concerne les gags attention ou
directives connaîtrez envoyée outre le
contrôle des médecins et une directive
qui est partie également de conseiller
dans les centres hospitaliers de
vacciner plus tôt la veille d'un jour de
congé que la veille de travailler quoi
donc ça fout une sale ambiance ça mais
une sale ambiance dans et c'est
contre-productif
laissons un peu de côté cette partie
administratifs et de bon sens du terrain
troisièmement je voulais vous demander
si vous pensez pas que le tribe l'âge au
lieu du 5 ans âge pouvait être quelque
part
ennuyeux pour la découverte de
varian merci on a fini avec les
questions merci de répondre orient sur
un mes collègues de patienter quelques
minutes pour désigner des rapporteurs
alors beaucoup de beaucoup de questions
que la vaccination soit la solution
appelée car une grande partie la
solution oui bien sûr pas tout à fait
toute la solution c'est évident que les
gestes barrière joue un rôle important
mais enfin bien sûr c'est un élément
central qui devrait permettre de sortir
du tunnel
la question du nom de l'os qui seront in
fine est administrée cet été on verra
bien je veux dire au delà des prévisions
pas seule chose que je peux vous dire
encore une fois c'est que le aujourd'hui
les pré commandes pour son elle que l'on
doit vouloir vacciner massivement les
nos concitoyens cet été et arriver à des
chiffres très élevés je le répète ça a
pas l'air de l'inquiéter trop moi ça
m'inquiète plus que vous pourvu que nos
concitoyens se soit d'accord se faire
vacciner je rappelle que les les
sondages indiquent que même si la
situation est meilleure et entre 30 et
40% des français qui sont pour l'instant
réticents la vaccination et que cela
prédomine chez les jeunes adultes entre
20 et 50 ans un peu plus les hommes que
les femmes et que là il ya un énorme
travail de pédagogie d'explication à
faire pour que la vaccination soit une
fine est un succès est ce qu'on peut se
procurer des vaccins ailleurs la réponse
à moins de faire comme les rois
je pense que ce n'est pas une bonne idée
en termes de sécurité pour concitoyens
sinon de ce que j'en sais ce juste pas
possible je répète dans tous les cas que
les autres pays la communauté européenne
à part l'amour y est je crois la pologne
la roumanie et asus pas vous la service
est plus un des pays de l est ne
n'utilise que les commandes provenant de
la commande commune européenne et qui a
une tension mondiale sur la production
de vaccins que vous savez on est encore
capable
il ya aujourd'hui je le chiffre de
personnes ou de doses administrées dans
le monde ces 4 %
et certains pays sont à zéro et une
façons et allant même des pays et zé
comme l'australie ou le japon ne compte
n'ont pas commencé à vacciner mais aussi
toute l'afrique n'a pratiquement pas
vaccinés et donc un effort mondial
acquis est absolument indispensable
aussi pour nous a amené une tension
parce qu'il n'a pas assez le vaccin est
un ensemble de produits nécessaires à la
fabrication des vaccins ou les leur
contenu les flacons le vert les bouchons
des choses qui paraissent trivial mais
qui sont malheureusement des facteurs
limitants qui font que l on peut pas
inventer des vaccins puisque ce qu'il y
a aujourd'hui les que je ne crois
vraiment pas même si je me suis pas
occupée directement que ça mais j'ai
entendu beaucoup d'exploser j'ai lu
beaucoup là dessus qu'on puisse obtenir
d'autres doses de vaccins que celles qui
sont ardemment négocier en permanence le
problème la problématique contamination
transmission alors j'ai n'ai pas dit que
il y avait forcément une contamination
possible des personnes vaccinées
j'ai dit plus tôt la baisse des dit
qu'il y avait un fort espoir que la
vaccination préviennent la transmission
mais on jure j'ai c'est d'être honnête
les données ne sont pas suffisantes pour
l'affirmer avec certitude mais j'ai
sûrement pas il inverse
donc j'ai plutôt un message d'optimisme
les d'optimisme prudent
les thérapeutiques puis vous aviez posé
valable à la question aussi quels sont
les thérapeutiques en utilise à bhl
bientôt utilisable et on essaie donc au
delà des médicaments déjà connu pour
diminuer significativement la mortalité
dans des formes les plus graves comme
les corticoïdes les anticoagulants par
exemple et certains traitements autres
anti-inflammatoires qui ont un certain
effet il y a potentiellement un intérêt
pour utiliser des anticorps monoclonaux
qui neutralise le virus qui agissent
directement sur le virus et qui sont ré
commises et maintenant pour les
personnes à risque les plus âgés mais il
faut que ce soit un ministre est assez
tôt dans la maladie parce qu'après on
sait que ça ne marche plus donc c'est
qu'il ya une fenêtre de tir qui est
limité mais c'est quand même une fenêtre
dans les médicaments qui sont testés il
ya l'interféron l'interféron c'est une
substance qui est anti viral et on sait
qu'elle joue un rôle important dans le
contrôle des infections virales
respiratoires et il ya des analyses en
cours de ces thérapeutiques en cours
d'administration là aussi il faut que ce
soit
ce après c'est trop tard le grand ancien
ministre et l'interférence soit par voie
respiratoire nasale soit pas voir
injection si cela apporte un bénéfice
et enfin il y à une série de molécules
antivirales qui sont en cours de test de
par le monde
il ya eu publication récent plus pour
agent pour l'une d'entre elles mais
aucune n'est validé à ce jour aucune
heureusement mais il sachet qui a
énormément d'efforts de recherche et
qu'on peut espérer voir émerger dans les
semaines qui viennent de telles
molécules
il faudra juste faire attention c'est
que il fonctionner plusieurs parce que
s'il devait y en avoir qu'une il est
très probable que très vite les virus
sera résistant y aura les mutations de
résistance comme avec les antibiotiques
et les bactéries par exemple ou avec le
virus vih
quand vous savez le pour contrôler le
vih vous administrez trois antiviraux
c'est ça peut être la même chose on
n'est pas tout à fait malheureusement
dans une situation où à court terme de
telles thérapeutique ne seront
utilisables
voilà un bref compte rendu de la
situation des concernant les
thérapeutiques utilisées sud africain le
vaccin riser et probablement une assez
bonne efficacité encore on n'a pas de
données cliniques
pour l'instant on a juste des données de
titres d'anticorps neutralisants qui
restent qui diminue un peu mais qui
reste pas trop mauvais relais gardien
sud africain
donc ça justifie bien sûr de l'utiliser
ce lac st il n'y a pour l'instant aucune
information du lupin au monde devrait
dire de résistance max 1 quel qu'il soit
il faut donner un message quand même qui
reste largement positif
donc bien sûr il peut être utilisé dans
les dom-tom bien sûr il faut développer
les je suis d'accord avec vous poussez
les centres de vaccination monte le nom
de doses convaincre la population de
l'importance de cette vaccination dans
les différents territoires
madame cohen avait une série de
questions ou de remarques vous dites je
vous reprenez la discussion sur le fait
qu'on a vu le verset le programme de
vaccination des mais ne sache pas tout à
fait d'accord même si je suis d'accord
que les choses n'ont pas été faites de
façon très à droite même unie pour n'a
perturbé quelque chose qui marchait je
rappelle qu'il ya
il y avait lundi quatre cent mille doses
de vaccin astrazeneca qui aurait dû être
administrés qui n'avait pas été
administrés ça marchait pas parfaitement
bien
ça peut s'expliquer encore une fois par
le fait que ça prend du temps que les
choses n'est jamais en place une
organisation quelconque et vaccinal en
particulier qui a pris beaucoup de monde
en trois jours mais enfin il ya des
progrès à faire
faut savoir par ailleurs qu'il se trouve
que cette semaine c'est pas de chance
mais la livraison des vaccins
astrazeneca est très irrégulière la
quantité de doses disponibles cette
semaine ses 280 milles alors que ça sera
je crois quatre ou trois ou quatre fois
plus la semaine suivante
donc ce qui permettra de reprendre sans
difficulté si tout le monde y met de la
bonne volonté une vaccination par les
médecins
bien évidemment il faut pas je passe à
votre question supplémentaire
je crois en la personne j'ose espérer un
peu les cas pas moi on pense qu'il faut
jeter l'opprobre sur les personnes
possible de santé je travaille tous les
jours avec de très nombreux
professionnels de santé je pense qu'il
n'y a pas de contre-indication de
contradictions excusez-moi entre le fait
de les applaudir ce qui était légitime
mais il reste légitime et de les inciter
à se vacciner et je pense que ça fait
partie d'une même conscience
professionnelle qui est que d'un côté on
se dévouent pour soigner des gens danger
et qu'on fait tout ce qu'il faut pour
les protégés se protéger soi-même et les
protéger et on sait que malheureusement
il ya eu quand même beaucoup
d'infections nosocomiales c'est-à-dire
de transmission du virus
alors ça peut être aussi par les
visiteurs des malades mais on sait qu'il
ya des cas documentés où ce sont des
problèmes de santé qui n'ont qu'à
terminer le malade doit lutter contre ça
j'espère bien comme vous on y arrivera
sans l'obligation vaccinale je l'espère
beaucoup je crois je crois en la justice
en la conscience professionnelle des
professionnels de santé
mais bon voilà il faut pas que ça que ça
traîne trop le passeport sanitaires il à
vrai dire truite une première
application que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure pour les ehpad et c'est bien
c'est qu'enfin les personnes vaccinées
peuvent sortir des pas d'aller visiter
leur famille c'est une forme de
passeports sanitaire puisque les
personnes non vaccinées
malheureusement ne le doivent pas pour
l'instant
ensuite une extension utilisation des
tests pour par exemple supérieurement
aller au restaurant pourquoi ça va pas
quand même être complètement simple s'il
faut faire un test bon ça prend 20
minutes mais la voie en entraînant le
restaurant la faisabilité
on va dire incertaine enfin vous évoquez
le fait de vacciner façon prioritaire
certaines professions et vous pensez aux
enseignants je peux parfaitement
comprendre qu'on pense aux enseignants
mais j'aurais dire si on pense aux
enseignants on doit évoquer toute une
série d'autres professions qui sont
largement exposés on peut penser aux
gens qui travaillent dans les commerces
les gens qui sont les services de
nettoyage les gens qui assurent les
systèmes sécurité ça fait beaucoup de
monde et in fine et on s'en sort pas
donc la seule solution réaliste c'est
d'arriver au plus vite à vacciner toute
la population
les enseignants qui ont des facteurs de
risque sont déjà vaccinés là peuvent
être vaccinés et les zones je l'espère
pourront l'être donc ici seulement nous
sommes en mars que ça puisse commencer
dans deux mois deux à trois mois au plus
tard on aura du mal à faire autrement et
d'ailleurs je me place soit dans aucun
pays même là où maxime très largement
israël dans une certaine mesure etats
unis grande bretagne ils n'ont pas fait
de priorisation par les professions pour
l'épauler pour les mêmes raisons vous
évoquez est par ailleurs la vaccination
des auxiliaires de vie aides infirmiers
à domicile et évidemment ces personnes
sont tout à fait légitimes largement si
légitime que les autres professionnels
de santé être vaccinés mettre en place
une filière privilégiée ça me paraît un
peu compliquée déjà les organisations
sont complexes il n'y a pas de raison a
priori qu'aider prennent deux rendez
vous si vous observez ces difficultés il
faut le faire remonter aussi haut niveau
de l' agence régionale de votre agence
régionale de santé
je pense que c'est plus des problèmes
d'organisation local on doit pouvoir
résoudre cette difficulté fournira
tableau d'honneur toutes les
informations que je les ai indiqué tout
à l'heure où il ya absolument je pense
que vous avez complètement raison il
faut le demander aux miss à ma santé qui
vous ne diffuser aucune raison que vous
n'ayez pas ces informations les avait
eus
et vous devez les avoirs inégalités de
répartition des vaccins
en principe il n'ya pas trop
d'inégalités et les critères de qui ont
été définis celle en fonction du nombre
de personnes éligibles en fonction des
priorités qui ont été définis par région
et par département et les ars ensuite
éventuellement s'adapte moi j'ai une
discussion notamment avec le directeur
de rs des hauts de france justement et
je sais qu'ils font des adaptations pour
résoudre des difficultés développement
qui est un effort qui est fait pour être
le plus équitable possible votre cri du
coeur madame pour concernant dunkerque
il fallait le pas de calais je le
comprends totalement et je ne peux
évidemment que vous suivre sur la
nécessité pour l'instant malheureusement
de confiner de vacciner je suis pas sûr
que les vaccins viennent un fonds dit
ouah c'est justement l'effort qui est
fait pour consolider la vaccination dans
un territoire qui en a le plus besoin
je pense que ceci on pose sur les
concertations entre grs élus locaux et
les professionnels de santé et il part
lire le vaccin pour ce qui est du black
swan fighter il peut pas être délivrée
chez les médecins et pose de ce travail
de conservation malheureusement on ne
peut les maximes et consentent
c'est juste pas possible de les apporter
chez chez des médecins mais au moins à
travers les mosquées du bassin finder
enfin vers les centres il faut bien sûr
aussi vivre cette campagne et je sais
que les iec grosse mobilisation pour que
faire en sorte que ça se passe au mieux
et le plus vite possible dans votre
région la problématique justement cette
période territorialisation se fasse aux
dépens des autres alors ça aurait été
absolument vrai jusqu'en janvier février
mais à partir du moment où quand même
moment de l'axé indisponible devient
franchement plus important je rappelle
que aumale mars le le rythme de
livraison et on est un ordre de grandeur
de deux millions de doses par semaine ça
donne quand même un petit peu de marge
de manoeuvre
heureusement sans être injuste à l'égard
des personnes qui en ont besoin dans
d'autres cas les toits
mal manger j'ai repéré que la
vaccination dans le grand des soucis
faisait allusion ne va mieux alors je
n'avais pas vu spécifiquement les
chiffres de la marne excusé voir mais
globalement j'ai vu que les chiffres de
grand est sont plutôt meilleurs que ce
que vous évoquez pour le pour la marne
sur les histoires de consigne des
contenants et je suis totalement
d'accord avec vous sur qu'il faut être
dans le bon sens et faire les choses le
cas le nom et s'abstraire de consigne
qu'ils soient de nature plus
administrative et enfin sur l'aspect
technique criblage séquençage il ya deux
niveaux c est qu on peut repérer les
verrions par des techniques de pca
particulière et ça c'est indispensable
séquençage il vient après on peut passer
quand c'est le virus de tout le monde
aucun pays du monde ne peuvent faire
cela mais donc ces choses se feront de
temps criblage permettant de repérer des
variants puis séquençage lorsqu'il ya
suspicion de variants mais maintenant le
système fonctionne bien on a des données
département mars par teva rtement santé
publique france 2 donne chaque semaine
on a des données très précises
concernant variant britannique qui est
largement et 2000 ou encore une fois est
un tout petit peu de des autres ballons
voilà on demandait madame la présidente
les perspectives pour les autres vaccins
le lac saint jean scène là ce n'est plus
un problème mais enfin ce n'est presque
plus un prêt de l'autorisation ce qu'il
est autorisé à vendre aux états unis il
l'aura il sera très poliment en erreur
prochainement
en termes de prévisions de livraisons il
reste encore un peu flou parce que
visiblement jones elle va servir de
façon prioritaire le territoire nord
américain
je sais qu'il ya des forces négociations
là dessus enfin il sera indisponible
entre la fin avril et mai le ver
s'incurve ac qui est à notre troisième
vaccin et rennes a pris un peu de retard
dans son développement
donc aujourd'hui les il est envisagé
qu'il puisse être utilisé en partie du
mois de juillet et enfin il ya le vaccin
de vaccin vaccin protéines pour lequel
ne s'est pas encore tout à fait précis
mais qui est aussi un vaccin intéressant
mais probablement de aussi est
disponible en début d'été voilà pour les
trois vaccins à venir en dehors des
trois nous disposons aujourd'hui
et enfin
poser une question sur marion
britannique est ce qu'il entraîne une
maladie et des symptômes différents pas
ma connaissance je n'ai pas entendu le
point vous évoquez sur le quai moins
souvent à cause de ce nid par exemple je
n'ai pas encore lu sa course que je ne
sais pour moi c'est qu'il est plus
contagieux jusqu'à quel point il ya
encore un peu de discussions mais il est
plus contagieux sans être apparemment
plus sévère évidemment s'il ya plus de
personnes malades ya plus de personnes
hospitalisées c'est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui il ya une tension sur dans
certains certaines régions de france
dont l'île de france d'en bas sur les
animations ont raison de ce niveau de
contagion plus élevé qui crée cette
tension pour l'instant persistante de la
pandémie en france
[Musique]